[Music]
foreign
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the columnist
and broadcaster Steve Richards and the
political commentator and former
conservative special advisor Sal
Michelle they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
other times quotes the General Secretary
of the Royal College of Nursing Pat
Cullen insisting that Rishi sunak needs
to get a grip and agree to negotiate
overpay with striking nurses
the mail reports that hospitals are
being urged to discharge as many
patients as they can before next week's
ambulance strikes
the express understands the king wants
to make peace with Prince Harry after
the disclosures of intimate family
conversations in his and Megan's Netflix
docu-series
the mirror says that whether or not they
reach a resolution his majesty doesn't
intend to address the matter publicly
and according to the telegraph the
sussexes will be invited to the
coronation in May
the guardian carries allegations that
traces of a substance believed to be
cocaine were found at a country house
used by Liz truss during her short-lived
Premiership Mr Strauss has insisted the
claims are categorically untrue
the sun claims the singer Gary Glitter
will soon leave a prison having served
around half of his 16-year sentence for
child sex offenses
the financial times says the Investment
Bank Goldman Sachs intends to make four
thousand of its staff redundant in an
attempt to boost profits
and the star
is that certain perfumes for sale this
Christmas apparently contain ingredients
more usually found in a lavatory
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Steve
Richards and Sal Michelle welcome to
both of you let us start with the mirror
under their coverage of uh the Lady
Susan and ngozi Fulani incident that
happened at the palace they have now met
a war meeting we're told and Lady Susan
has apologized in person Steve
well I I think this is a sort of story
with a wider message about the need for
the monarchy to modernize
um you know I've I'm still not quite
sure what the role of Lady and waiting
is if that is the title of um uh the
person who's apologized forgive me when
I forget the names I really don't follow
the ins and outs
Lady Susan healthy
and the reason I don't yeah
um I kind of vaguely knew her husband
Duke Hussey when he was chair of the BBC
but
um you see there's a sort of impression
and it's a dangerous one that we know
all these people we know the context in
which quotes appear and we really don't
um but if she has uh some kind of
reconciliation uh I guess that's a a
good thing but
um it's a relatively peripheral thing
frankly compared with these sort of
bizarre roles and titles and everything
that accompany the paraphernal of the
monarchy at the end of another week
where the soap opera has reached
intense and in some ways I think quite
significant proportions but that's a
different story
salma's uh giggling um Salma what do you
make available they're pictured both
smiling
um I'm surprised that Steve's cynicism
in all of this because actually it seems
to be a lovely story to me
um you know two people had a falling out
and it's one of those things that's
become a bit of a culture clash in the
UK you know understanding people's
backgrounds understanding where they
come from and we've had actually a
grown-up resolution to this conflict in
that lady season hussy made some um
comments that were
um offensive and you know so you know
people felt hurt by it but they've come
together they've apologized they've
accepted the apology the apology has
been accepted and we've now been able to
move forward I think it's a really good
example of how you can do something
without conflict let's just ignore the
wider point that you're making Steve for
just just a slight moment and just focus
on the fact that actually you can get
through a conflict and you can resolve
it without
um you know continuing with strong
language and sort of whipping up
people's uh prejudices
go ahead Steve
yeah it's a really nice photo and I
completely agree with what salmon has
been saying about it it's just you know
it is it is so difficult to comment on
these things compared say with politics
where actually you can really delve deep
and get to know the people and what they
represent and so on we we really are
always uh sort of on the surface at best
with these stories and I'm sort of
uneasy about them and even when I hear
Royal Specialists commentating I'm never
wholly sure about how much they know and
I can't pretend to know anything about
it so but I agree it's a lovely photo
and Thelma just just briefly do you
think this has uh drawn a line under
that this issue because ngozi Fulani
faced a barrage a backlash on on social
media
um and it is a photo is it is it a PR
stunt to say that everything's all right
but but really it's we've just
scratch the surface
ultimately everything like this is you
can categorize it as a PR stunt because
it's it's a communication to the public
that is trying to manage a situation so
you can absolutely be cynical about it
but ultimately both women have come
together and they're trying to put their
differences aside and I think lady
Hussey has been open about the fact that
she is willing to be a bit more educated
and aware about the issues that
sometimes cause offense to people you
know everybody in this country who is
from an ethnic minority background
probably has some experience of being
asked where are you really from I know I
have but the intention is that malicious
but in the in the statement that's
released by Buckingham Palace it draws
out the horrific abuse uh that ngozi
Fulani has been experiencing on social
media and condemns it and I think that
was a really important thing to do as
well
um and people do get wound up by these
things you know Steve is right you know
it's all these figures that don't really
mean anything to anybody but it doesn't
stop people from feeling her upsets you
know becoming a keyboard Warrior about
it and trolling others on Twitter so I
think it's it's actually really positive
um even if it is just one photo it draws
the line somewhere and and moves it on
okay we're gonna stay with the royal
family
um to your Delight Steve and we read in
the express that King Charles wants to
make peace with with Harry or is still
seeking peace with Harry
yeah of course it's he's a father of a
son and also what would be the biggest
story
um him briefing one way or another that
he was going to take on is uh start and
challenge him and exclude him from the
coronation that would fuel this drama
um and so the sensible thing is to brief
that that is what is happening I
actually don't think uh this isn't uh
the significance of this story is the
internal Feud within the royal family I
think it is much more and I have watched
some of the Netflix episodes
um a couple it's a sort of diana-like
insurrection actually against the media
much more than within the royal family
and I think it's Brave of them I'm I'm
on their side with this I mean I think
newspapers uh in Britain are still out
of control post that Diana period and
it's very brave to take them up and one
of the reasons why there is so much
angry coverage is that newspapers can
dish it out in Britain but they really
don't like taking it and
um so I think it's a very interesting
Insurrection but I think it is more a
revolt against the media but it
obviously then has explosive uh
implications for a royal family that has
to work with the media so that is the
route which I think is very interesting
that that is an interesting take and not
not one that many people have have taken
Steve
um to the mirror and we read there that
the the king and the the other Royals
have opted for silence
Selma is that the best optional or
should they really be answering some of
Harry's claims
well I think the problem is that you
know as it says that they're putting
dignity first because
they are still public figures they are
still important constitutionally you
know the king is the head of state and
playing this out and you know trying to
respond to it there are no winners there
and he's got an important job that he
needs to get on it and do and not be
sidetracked by what is essentially a
family drama laying out now that's not
to try and minimize what that you can
touch the Sussex feel you know they've
endured and encountered but it's one of
those things that even I feel sort of
uncomfortable talking about it because
it is essentially a private family
matter and I think it's for the king and
the royal family to deal with this
privately
um trying to respond to it and trying to
do it through the papers is is not going
to be helpful for anyone in a situation
uh and Steve do you think that's uh
wherein the problem lies that that um
Prince Harry has been guilty of washing
dirty laundry in in public and it's it's
a private Affair but now that he has
made it public
it's very difficult for the rest of the
Royal Family
yeah although I think they have opted
for the only route available for them
which is a sort of dignified silence
where no doubt those around them will
brief newspapers at certain point and
journalists will phone in and say oh is
the king going to retaliate against this
and thus and the The Briefing is no he
won't he wants to seek some kind of
reconciliation to use that word again
that becomes front page story and on it
goes but as I say I think the most
interesting element of it really is I
always wondered what would have happened
had Diana lived in terms of the impact
on the royal family and the media of
this kind of frankly intellectually
figure we don't have many troublemakers
in the British establishment and this
Duo whether you like them or not are
troublemakers and
um they're clearly not going to be
silenced they're clearly doing it for
all kinds of motives but I think one of
them is that Diana related horror of the
way the media treats
public figures including themselves and
I know people are going to say
immediately but they manipulate the
media sure so did Diana and so do many
others but I think it is on that level
quite Brave of them and I think there
will be
waves and consequences arising from it
uh which are quite interesting welcome
back you're watching the Press preview
still with me Steve Richards and Salma
Shah let's have a look at the times and
uh the quote there on the front page
sunac needs to get a grip who is saying
this and why Salma
well this is Pat Cullen uh the union
chief of the nurses uh who actually what
this piece shows is that uh tensions are
right rising in these negotiations
because there has been some briefing to
the times to suggest that Steve Barkley
the health secretary
um has been quite confrontational in
meetings which of course has been denied
by the government and so the Union uh
bosses are asking Rishi to get a grip on
the situation and you know it's actually
it's even it's even worse than just a
sort of a situation about pay at the end
of the piece there is some discussion
about foreign nurses being brought in
from Africa and Asia being likened to
trafficking of nurses so the language is
getting increasingly hostile uh I think
and it doesn't bode well for these
negotiations to come to any kind of
conclusion at the same time as we're
going to talk about in a bit more detail
uh that hospitals are being asked to
discharge patients to free up beds yes
and uh Steve Pat Cullen
um is pinning the the blame personally
on Steve Barkley it seems accusing him
of failing to Value caring professionals
dominated by women and struggling to
control his anger during face-to-face
talks it's not going well at all
no and you know in a way of course the
key to any resolution is in the
substance but but tone matters too you
know if you've got a sense that you're
in negotiation with someone who you can
respect and to some extent trust there
is greater scope for coming together
clearly uh the relationship between Pat
callant and Steve Barclay is pretty
disastrous
um with her comments on him as you say
they deny it but I mean all we've got is
that's what she thinks of him so on that
level it's not working it is interesting
the sunac role is I find fascinating I
assumed
um that although in some ways he would
be quite a weak figure it's it's a
massively fast elevation to the top that
he would have language and a certain
Authority
um but both seem to me to be lacking in
in this he's a rather Ghostly figure in
the context of the public Narrative of
the government's position and I wonder
like a lot of chancellors who become
Prime Minister he ca has yet anyway you
know he's a human being and it's all
very sudden that he's in number 10. he
can't really Master a whole series of
crises at the same time which is the art
of leadership at the very top
um in the treasury you prepare for a
budget a public spending statement here
you've got to really be on top of
everything all the time and I see little
evidence that he is Salma do do you
agree
with that
I think I think it's slightly unfair to
Rishi because this is not a sort of
normal period of government he hasn't
come in as leader coming out of
opposition with a game plan he had a
leadership contest that was essentially
as we all know pretty bungled because
we've had three prime ministers this
year but you know Rishi sunaka's
Chancellor had to deal with the pandemic
he is now as prime minister having to
deal with The Economic Consequences of
that pandemic alongside a pretty ropey
budget I might say that you know only
occurred a couple of months ago
um so trying to manage whilst I I agree
with that the art of leadership is
managing several crises at a time I do
think that actually given where he is in
the cycle
given what he's actually facing there is
an argument to suggest that actually he
is allowing his cabinet and in this case
his health secretary to deal with it if
he does need to step in then that's
going to be a much bigger deal